>> HOW DO YOU DO FELLOW KIDS?
>> Jesse: DANA LOESCH JOINS US
NOW.
SO YOU GET TO SEE FETTERMAN ON
NETFLIX NOW ALONGSIDE CHRISTIAN
BALE.
WHAT A RISE TO FAME.
HOW DID THAT HAPPEN, DANA?
>> IT'S A GREAT QUESTION, JESSE.
HOW DID THAT HAPPEN?
YOU KNOW WHAT THEY NEVER SAY
THAT HE LOOKS LIKE?
THEY NEVER SAY HE LOOKS LIKE A
SENATOR.
THEY NEVER SAY THAT HE LOOKS
LIKE A PROFESSIONAL.
LIKE A GROWN MAN.
HE HAS THE STYLE OF A TEENAGE
BOY WHO IS FORCED TO HALF WAY
DRESS UP BY THEIR PARENTS JUST
TO GO OUT TO EAT AT APPLEBEE'S.
THAT'S HIS WHOLE SCHTICK.
THAT'S HIS EVERY MAN.
LET'S NOT FORGET THAT A GREAT
PIECE, I CAN'T REMEMBER WHO
WROTE IT AT THE TIME.
RIGHT BEFORE THE ELECTION.
JOHN FETTERMAN, HE IS ABLE TO
REACH ACROSS THESE LINES AND
REACH OUT TO THESE BLUE COLLAR
WORKERS THAT REPUBLICANS HAVE
BEEN WINNING BECAUSE HE LOOKS
THE PART OF THE EVERY MAN.
BECAUSE DEMOCRATS THINK THE
EVERY MAN DOESN'T OWN LIKE A
BUTTON UP SHIRT.
THEY THINK THAT EVERY MAN
DOESN'T OWN A PAIR OF NICE SHOES
AND EVERY MAN ALL THEY EVER DO
IS WEAR HOODIES AND SHORTS EVEN
IF IT'S 20 DEGREES OUTSIDE.
THEY ARE TRYING TO MAKE HIM INTO
SOMETHING THAT NO ONE BELIEVES
THAT HE IS.
I THINK INCLUDING HIMSELF.
>> Jesse: FETTERMAN IS AN EXTRA
IN A MOVIE BEING PRODUCED BY THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
HE IS A STUNT DOUBLE.
HE -- LIKE, LET'S JUST SEE WHAT
WE CAN DO HERE?
GIVE HIM A LITTLE HAIR AND
MAKEUP.
THROW A HOODIE ON HIM.
WE'RE SO POWERFUL WE COULD MAKE
THIS GUY INTO THE NEXT U.S.
SENATOR.
YOU KNOW, MAKE HIM APPEALING TO
THE WORKING MAN.
HE DOESN'T REALLY HAVE TO SAY
MUCH OR DO MUCH.
THIS IS WHAT WE'RE CAPABLE OF.
AND I FEEL LIKE NOW THEY ARE
COCKY AND THEY COULD PRETTY MUCH
RUN ANYTHING FOR A SENATE AT
THIS POINT.
>> LET THEM BE COCKY THAT'S
THEIR ACHILLES HEEL.
DON'T INTERRUPT THEM.
>> LET THEM FEEL THAT WAY.
CAN YOU IMAGINE LIVING JOHN
FETTERMAN'S LIFE A LIFE OF
PRIVILEGE WHERE YOU DON'T
ACTUALLY HAVE TO DO ANY WORK?
YOU GET AN ALLOWANCE FROM YOUR
PARENTS UP UNTIL YOUR 50'S.
YOU DON'T EVER ACTUALLY WORK IN
THE PRIVATE SECTOR EXCEPT MAYBE
A BARELY TWO YEAR STINT AS AN
INSURANCE AGENT AND THEN YOU
BECOME MAYOR AND YOU DON'T DO
ANYTHING AND YOUR DEMOCRAT CITY
COUNCIL DISLIKES YOU AND WANTS
YOU INVESTIGATING TO THE
AUTHORITY OF THE LOCAL POLICE TO
DOX YOUR DISSENTERS AND THEN
BECOME LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR WHERE
YOU STILL DON'T DO ANYTHING AND
NOW BE SENATOR WHERE HE DOESN'T
DO ANYTHING EITHER, JESSE.
I DON'T KNOW IF ANYTHING CAN S.
GOING TO CHANGE IN THE SENATE.
HE WILL BE TOO BUSY HIMSELF AND
EVERY MAN AND DOING NETFLIX
MOVIES NOW.
>> Jesse: GISELE IS HAVING THE
TIME OF HER LIFE AND THAT IS
WHAT MATTER.
>>